hallo mein name ist luca und meine
zuschauer durften mir auch twitter
videos einsenden wie sie versuchen
germany's next topmodel zu sein und das
ist irgendwie nach hinten losgegangen
das ist kriege ich sogar auch noch hin
du musst dich ich weiß nicht was sie da
am ende sagen wollte aber ich glaube das
war irgendwas in die richtung luca
wiener shop.de da wurde nur der ton
irgendwie abgeschnitten aber hey hier
gebe ich eine 5 von 10
[Musik]
warum hast du eine maske auf die türen
ich will dir in meiner zehner bewertung
auf jeden fall eine sechs von zehn geben
warum kommt jedes mal dieses beschissene
horrorladen aber okay wir schauen wie
der catwalk vom horror hinaus sieht guck
mal was ich hier in dieser box habe du
kannst es dir bestimmt schon denken
richtig das ist der dritte gelbes wetter
damit gehe ich auf dem gntm geht work
dankeschön die besserungen das duo aus
meinem shop ist weiter bestellt das
freut mich auf jeden fall sehr dass auch
tiere meine klamotten mögen ganz kurze
werbung hier noch mal eben freunde und
zwar kommt in vier tagen eine neue
kollektion online in meinem shop die
shop adresse kennt glaube ich jeder
minister und die beiden special artikel
also die jeansjacke und direktes jacke
werden nicht in einer normalen
plastiktüte wie sonst mal kommen sondern
die kommen in einer wirklich schwarzen
box also allein die box kostet irgendwie
6 euro oder so das habe ich nur bisher
noch nicht erwähnte m und was ich auch
nur in dem gntm blog nebenbei gesagt
habe ist das ist auch wieder 1000
signiertes ticker geben wird also ja
erst 6 15 uhr und jetzt gucken wir mal
war dass das horn
sitzt ja wie angegossen ausgezeichnet
aber mal schauen ob das hoch und jetzt
wirklich mit dem zweiter hier einen
catwalk macht wir machen weiter ich habe
bei twitter geschrieben wir sollten wir
videos einsenden wie ihr lauft nicht wie
eine capri sonne läuft erstmal danke für
deine tolle einsendungen ich habe das
auch gerade beim horror um komplett
vergessen zu bewerten
ist aber auch egal dieses
bewertungsschema macht ihr kein seinen
dank an auf jeden fall auch hier für
deinen catwalk was ich am meisten fand
weil diese ja ich sehe was auch immer
das sein sollte dieses haare nach hinten
schmeißen
das war es wohl keinen kennt worden
sondern eine doku ja danke danke schön
[Musik]
wie wenig hobbys kammern haben also an
der stelle muss ich ganz wirklich mal
sagen das hast du gar nicht so schlecht
gemacht
juli kennst du das auf
in winder wochen das war ehrlich gesagt
auch gar nicht mal so schlecht freunde
germany's next topmodel 2009 10 werde
ich aber 2020 könnte die retter werden
ich nehme das zurück was ich gerade
gesagt habe warum habt ihr alle eine
maske auf warum ich einfach dass videos
noch nicht zu ende aber an der stelle
muss man fast sagen und zwar fällt mir
auf dass leute das entweder komplett
beschiss machen dann gegen mittag ab wie
sonne oder mit den fingern oder halt
wirklich ernst nehmen und ich glaube sie
nimmt es ernst aber wir schauen mal
weiter
meine fresse wie siehst du aus was bist
du anders nämlich das heutige video
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren man ja eine folge reagiert ein
bisschen kürzer diesmal einem tut mir
leid aber ich musste das heute relativ
schnell alles fertig stellen das ganze
video wenns euch vielleicht trotzdem
gefallen hat das gerne mal einen like da
sollte ich mal malen keine ahnung
schreiben kommentare topmodel
wenn ja noch